a man without any military experience
has just become our nation's first
female four-star admiral
according to the news media dr rachel
levine has become
the nation's first female four-star
admiral the only problem with those news
reports is that he is not a four-star
admiral and he isn't
a female and he isn't rachel he's
richard
but our news media and our government
have little to do with reality these
days so according to them dr levine has
just shattered the glass ceiling you go
girl i'm michael knowles this is the
michael nolan show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from george rapco who
says in august we mocked the taliban for
not being able to run an airport in
october we applauded the secretary of
transportation in america for not being
able to run a shipping dock yes that is
true it would seem that before we start
throwing stones
and mocking other people we ought to
take a look at ourselves
levine
rachel levine as he is now called but
whose real name is richard levine
is a man who believes that he is a woman
and he is the assistant secretary for
health
that fact alone
is a an indictment of our country
okay i don't i don't want it i want to
be mean here but this is a very very
confused individual and this very very
confused individual
who is
deluded about very basic aspects of
reality
is the assistant secretary for health in
the united states and no longer just the
assistant secretary for health but
technically a four-star admiral now this
is a little bit confusing because you're
you know you're you're expecting when
you think of an admiral you think of
john mccain senior or something like
that right you're when you think of an
admiral or a general you're thinking of
macarthur or patton but but mr levine is
an admiral in the u.s public health
services commissioned corps
so this is much more an honorary title
than it is you know
this guy storming the beaches of iwo
jima or something
he is the nation's first openly
transgender four-star officer
across any of the eight uniformed
services the five military services and
then the other ones
this according to an hhs press release
health and human services
and what they also say is quote today's
historic announcement builds on the
accomplishments of lgbtq
plus history month and is a major step
forward as we work to create a more
inclusive society so
dr levine is not
being given this title because of
anything he has done you can read it
just in the press release he's being
given this because of what he represents
because he identifies as a woman
and this is part of the lgbtq
umbrella and this month and i know this
part's confusing too is also lgbtq month
now you might have thought michael i
thought lgbtq month was back in june
back when we had all the pride parades
that month is also lgbtq month so we now
have a full one-sixth of the year
dedicated to unusual sexual desires
i assume there's going to be a third
month added at some point in the near
future pretty soon it will just be
lgbtq year and it'll just be every
single month of the year
dr levine for his part says quote i am
humbled to serve as the first female
four-star officer of the u.s public
health service
and first openly transgender four-star
officer across the uniformed services
this is a momentous occasion and i'm
pleased to take this role for the impact
i can make for the historic nature of
what it symbolizes may this appointment
be the first of many like it as we
create a more inclusive future we are
living in clown world folks this is not
something that a serious society does
and but we are no longer a serious
society and we no longer have even the
tenuous grasp on reality that we have in
recent years that's gone that's totally
severed when you have a dude as the
first female four-star officer and it's
not even like really a four-star officer
it's a public health role
you've lost the threat you've lost it
and it's not it's
no knock on him he's a confused person
who who should receive help
but it is a knock on us because
that that is not inclusive or diverse or
equitable or compassionate to anybody
when you have a society
that is living in lies and fantasy and
delusion and it's also disrespectful
even of this guy because as even he is
acknowledging his appointment has
basically nothing to do with his
accomplishments or his unique abilities
and it has everything to do with the
fact that he mistakenly believes himself
to be a woman
also what about the women what about the
women don't wouldn't it be nice if a
woman were the first female whatever
don't you i mean you would think you
would think that if women deserve
anything the women deserve to be the
first woman whatever but they're not now
the men are the first women whatever
margaret atwood who is the author of uh
what is that awful a handmaid's tale so
margaret atwood wrote handmaid's tale
and that's what the tv series is based
on this dystopian future in which women
are oppressed and everything's terrible
margaret atwood has come out and
questioned some of this madness
some of this transgender madness
not directly speaking to
dr levine or any of these people
individually but just retweeting a
column it was in the toronto star
headline is why can't we say woman
anymore we're not allowed to say woman
we have to refer to person with a cervix
we need to refer to person who
menstruates we need to refer to birthing
people but we're not allowed to say
woman and margaret atwood says hold on
wait
why why can't we say
woman
you know what this shows is
something ironic it's something
conservatives have known for a very long
time but the libs have have deluded
themselves as they want to do which is
that the real handmaid's tale by which
we mean the real oppression of women
such as it is
does not come from the right it doesn't
come from conservatives it doesn't come
from christians it comes from the libs
it comes from the libs who are in this
case erasing women from the public
square and giving women's jobs to men
and pretending that men are women but
but it's been going on for a long time
from the left side of the political
equation
it's been going on since
the second wave feminists said a woman
needs a man like a fish needs a bicycle
at least since that time just look at
the public opinion surveys it's very
difficult to measure happiness and i'm
skeptical of social science but every
survey
of women's happiness since this
gender-bending second wave of feminism
has shown that
women's happiness has declined it has
not increased it's declined both
relative to the happiness of men and in
absolute terms
why is that because it turns out that
having men behave or having women rather
behave like men in the workplace in
their personal relationships in every
aspect of society doesn't actually make
women happier the lib view of of men and
women
going back at least to the second wave
feminists and really earlier is that men
and women are identical
the conservative view of men and women
is that men and women are complementary
so in the libview
men the only differences between men and
women are superficial any differences
that may
result in society between men and women
are obviously the result of oppression
and women need to just do whatever men
do
the christian conservative view is that
men need women and women need men and we
to go we go together and that's what
forms the family and that's what forms
society and it's a wonderful thing and
there will never be a war between the
sexes because everyone is sleeping with
the enemy it's the christian view and it
happens to be
correct
and it turns out that that view the idea
that men and women are different is is
actually not the oppressive one the
oppressive one comes from those who
would deny the differences between the
sexes speaking of men taking jobs from
women
pete buddha judge remains on paternity
leave i think he might be winding it
down though because he's getting a lot
of negative flack for this
so pete buddha judge goes on cnn he goes
on jake tapper's show to address the
preposterous fact that he has been on
paternity leave for two months
amid a major transportation crisis and
he says
he's not going to apologize
this is the first time you've been on
the show since you and your husband
chaston welcomed twins penelope and
joseph
into your family you just returned from
paternity leave which congress is
debating right now some conservatives
have been citing
your experience in an effort to mock the
very idea of paternity leave take a
listen
pete but a judge has been on leave from
his job since august after adopting a
child paternity leave they call it
trying to figure out how to breastfeed
no word on how that went
what's your response as you might
imagine we're bottle feeding and doing
it at all hours of the day and night
and i'm not going to apologize to tucker
carlson or anyone else
for taking care of my premature newborn
infant twins the work that we are doing
is joyful fulfilling wonderful work
it's important work and it's work that
every american ought to be able to do
when they welcome a new child into their
family
it is joyful work it is important work
to raise a baby it is
and
families should do that
cabinet secretaries
don't get to play stay-at-home mom
forever they don't get to do it
you can do you can
do either one you can either be a
cabinet secretary and do your job or you
can play stay-at-home mom you can't do
both you actually can't have it all i
agree with buda judge frankly i think
that
being a mom and raising a baby and being
the the hand that rocks the cradle and
rules the world i think that's much more
important than being the transportation
secretary okay i actually don't think
it's that
cool or great a thing to be the
transportation secretary
but if that is your view then quit buddy
and let some because someone does
actually have to do that job so quit let
somebody do that job and you can play
stay-at-home mom and and play with your
kids and that that's fine that's a great
but you you can't have it all and it's
not just bootage
it's a lie that our society has told
ourselves that we can do everything we
don't have to make any sacrifices and we
never have to have any limits or make
any choices and that is just a fantasy
when you want to limit the number of
people who are coming into your house
unannounced i would strongly recommend
you check out ring you know i was i was
on the road last week with my friend
senator ted cruz for our verdict live
tour and it was a whole lot of fun but i
know that sometimes my wonderful wife
and cute little baby
get a little bit nervous when i'm not in
the house okay this is why i am so
thankful for ring ring alarm will allow
you to see and speak to whoever is at
your door you you're very well aware of
their wonderful doorbell and camera but
they'll let you keep an eye on every
inch of your home inside outside the
home you can control it all from an app
if things go bump in the night you don't
need to be too worried the house starts
creaking or something or if you've got
someone showing up to your door a
delivery man or a pizza guy or your
in-laws and who knows
how you're going to react to any of
those things ring makes it really easy
it's so simple to install even i can do
it and it's extremely inexpensive
protect your home anywhere anytime with
ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles for a special offer on the ring
alarm security kit today build a system
that's right for your home have it up
and running in minutes ring.com knowles
ring.com
knowles
speaking of babies
the cdc has just
accidentally admitted that abortion is
infanticide
how did they do this
well the way they did that is by
admitting that an unborn baby is in fact
a baby the left tries to pretend now
that
unborn babies are not babies they say oh
it's a fetus they don't know that the
latin word fetus means offspring it
means baby they'll say it's an embryo
okay well what is an embryo an embryo is
a small little baby it's a they'll use
kind of silly terms that they don't even
really know what they mean they'll say
it's a zygote zygote meaning that very
earliest
version of an embryo which
no babies that are that are aborted or
really are but they'll say that but sure
it's a baby it's a baby it's a baby it's
a baby so the cdc tweets out quote
did you know
that after receiving a tdap vaccine
during pregnancy your body creates
protective antibodies and passes some of
them to your baby before birth
yes we did know that but
but what does this mean
it means that your baby is a baby and
it's not just a baby after birth it's a
baby before birth which means that if
your baby is a baby before birth then
killing that baby is infanticide this is
not very sophisticated logic here folks
we're talking really basic stuff
and
i think the reason the cdc tweeted this
out and i think the reason that it
hasn't gotten more play
is that everyone knows
at least on some level that babies are
babies
and we like to delude ourselves and we
like to deny it i mean this is the
thread that's running through our entire
culture now is just a deep level of
denial based on preposterous ideologies
that have no relation to reality but i
think we all know deep down that the
baby actually is a baby this is why in
at least many states if you kill a
pregnant mother you are charged with
double murder
but
if that mother goes to an abortion
clinic and a doctor kills that baby it's
not it's a wonderful choice it's a
wonderful free reproductive health
women's rights choice but it's the exact
same action and the same action can't be
two contradictory things at the same
time
in the cdc the gr follow the science the
great authority of the cdc is admitting
that this is the case and the question
for us politically is okay we know the
science we know that
the baby is a baby and anyone who is
being honest with himself will admit
that so what are we going to do about it
naomi wolff the feminist but at least
she's something of an more honest
feminist naomi wolfe came out some years
ago and said look we need abortion and
abortion's good and we should support
abortion but we need to admit that we're
killing a baby in his full humanity and
we're doing it for the autonomy of women
so that we can
pretend that men and women are exactly
the same and they won't have any unique
constraints or limits or or
responsibilities so okay at least that's
a somewhat honest argument the left
can't bear that argument because it's so
deeply immoral
so they they pretend otherwise but
i think the the first step to recovering
from a problem is admitting that you
have a problem okay the first step is
acknowledging reality and we're
pretty far gone there so i think that's
the first thing we've got to establish
speaking of kids
terry mcauliffe terry mcauliffe the
former governor of virginia
wants to be the future governor of
virginia he's a democrat of the very
slimy clinton model i wouldn't call him
the most idealistic
democrat he's just a kind of a
sleazeball corrupt politician has very
little respect for his constituents
terry mcauliffe got in trouble because
terry mcauliffe said that kids should
not have any say or that parents rather
should not have any say in their kids
education take a listen
you said you don't believe parents
should be telling schools what to teach
what did you mean by that well first of
all parents should be telling schools
that they want their teachers to be
vaccinated do you think parents should
have a say in the curriculum you don't
want parents coming in in every
different school jurisdiction you
alluded to parents staying out of this
we just want to make sure that we're
understanding you correctly uh what is
your stance on that as far as what
school agendas have to say for the kids
first of all this is determined by the
state board of education and local
school boards
and that's where it should be do you
still stand by your position that
parents should not tell the schools what
they should teach
you do not want 25 parents picking books
but call us reply we have a board of ed
and we have local school boards who make
the decisions about teaching i'm not
going to let parents come into schools i
don't think parents should be telling
schools what they should teach i don't
think parents should be telling schools
what they should teach
there you go okay so that's an ad from
glenn younkin who's the republican
running against mcauliffe mcauliffe
could not possibly be clear he said it
on multiple occasions in multiple places
parents should have no say in how their
kids are brought up and how their kids
are educated and what their kids are
learning
that one line
is very possibly going to cost him this
election virginia is a blue state
terry mcauliffe has already been the
governor there and yet
they're running a pretty tight race
right now and it's because of this line
because it turns out parents don't like
being told that they have no role in
bringing up their kids so now what is
mcauliffe doing he's denying that he
ever said it
as parents dorothy and i have always
been involved in our kids education we
know good schools depend on involved
parents that's why i want you to hear
this from me
glenn younkin's taking my words out of
context i've always valued the concerns
of parents it's why as governor we
scaled back standardized testing
expanded pre-k and invested a billion
dollars in public schools i'm terry
mcauliffe candidate for governor and i
sponsored this ad because working
together we can give our kids the
education they deserve
what
did you not maybe he didn't listen to
the first clips where he says parent
parents should not be involved in the
kids schools parents should not be
picking books the state board of
education should pick everything
absolutely the parents should have no
role here in the schools
glenn younkin my opponent is taking my
words out of context what conte there
were like 10 contexts and they all said
the exact same thing
we i love parents it's good for parents
to be involved please vote for me please
i didn't realize my comments are out of
context out of context is
increasingly the way that democrats try
to wiggle out of lies
okay when when you
catch a democrat in a
lie they'll try to weasel out of it look
a lot of people try to weasel out of
lies in politics but democrats in
particular get a little cover here
because they control the media and the
education system and the fact checkers
and big tech so they've got a lot of
cover to kind of weasel out of lies and
twist everything but when you've got
them dead to rights do you know what
they say they say it's missing context
and you see this in all of the quote
unquote fact checker left-wing outlets
and you see it in all of the little
warning signs on on big tech posts when
a republican catches a democrat and a
lie they'll say no it's missing context
and the context is you shouldn't worry
about this because the democrat is good
the
the context you're missing is terry
mcauliffe good glenn younkin bad so you
might think because you're listening to
the words of terry mcauliffe that that
maybe he's bad and junkin's good but the
context you're missing is
democrat good that's it what other
context could there be here that that
they're missing nothing he terry
mcauliffe is lying
you can see it you listen to the words
yourself
but the question is
do the libs have enough of a lock on the
media and on the power structure that
he'll be able to get away with it
speaking of schools there's a story very
few people are talking about but i think
it's important because it gets not just
to this battle between the dems and the
republicans or the libs and the
conservatives or whatever it gets to a
kind of structural problem in our in our
system
public schools in baltimore right now
are monitoring student activities using
software that recognizes certain words
and phrases and then alerts school
officials that a student might be in
this case contemplating suicide
so it's not that the school is looking
for students
you know typing in some naughty words to
look at
images they shouldn't be
it's not that the schools are monitoring
students looking for other naughty words
that are suggesting that students are
looking at political websites that they
shouldn't be right it's not even that
it's specifically on this issue of
suicide now the baltimore sun is calling
the system controversial and pointing
out they were added to laptops during
the lockdowns
when the students were using school
laptops at home and now some people are
pushing back against it some people are
fine with it and the the issue doesn't
cut exactly down
party lines i don't think this issue is
quite so simple as privacy versus safety
much like i don't think our debate over
free speech or
political correctness really is so
simple as free speech versus censorship
for starters if you're going to use the
school laptop you're going to have to
deal with the school surveillance he who
pays the piper calls the tune
now also kids need some breadth to make
mistakes and implore explore some crazy
ideas and recognize that everything a
kid types into a search bar is not
something that they're seriously
considering or seriously going to do
kids also however need supervision
right and so i just think this is a
great issue to show and also it's not
like kids have absolute total rights
against their teachers coming in and
controlling what they do the the
teachers are standing in the place of
the parents that's part of their job
they're helping to educate and raise the
kids and that involves some degree of
coercion i think what what is helpful
here is not ideology not five bullet
points on a napkin
not just these slogans privacy versus
surveillance i think what's important
here is prudence okay
what are the schools looking at what are
they trying to stop what are the limits
i think if conservatives engage in this
issue but really in politics broadly
from lesser perspective of these
absolutes these slogans and bumper
stickers and we get a little bit more
prudential what issue let's not talk
about vaccines in general let's talk
about this vaccine let's not talk about
lockdowns in general let's talk about
this lockdown let's not talk about
surveillance in general let's talk about
this specific surveillance i think we're
going to have a much better argument to
make and a much better chance at winning
you know ben is going to be talking
today about how to defeat the
authoritarian left
that's the title of the show so go check
that out today also go check out morning
wire you can subscribe and start
listening to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts leave a five star review if you
like what you hear we'll be right back
with a lot more
you may have noticed that things cost a
little bit more money these days gas
costs more eggs cost more milk costs
more you may have noticed it's harder to
get things that you want to get the
stores are increasingly bare
and the authorities are telling you
get ready because the stores are not
going to be that well stocked you might
not be able to get christmas presents
for your kids
well the washington post is here to tell
you
to stop complaining about that
this this was an amazing opinion piece
from
micheline maynard
in the wapo headline
don't rant about short staffed stores
and supply chain woes
goes on to set up the issue and says
american consumers
their expectations pampered and catered
to for decades
are not accustomed to inconvenience
customers persistent wine why don't they
just hire more people sounds feeble
in this era of the great resignation
especially in industries such as food
service with reputations for being tough
places to work rather than living
constantly on the verge of throwing a
fit and risking taking it out on
overwhelmed servers struggling shop
owners or late arriving delivery people
we do ourselves a favor by consciously
lowering expectations
okay so first
just in general it's always good to be
polite to people it's always good to be
charitable and compassionate
that's not what this column is saying
what this what this column is saying
is just the latest and most extreme
expression of something that the left
has been telling us for decades
lower
your expectations
lower your expectations
don't do as much
don't drive as much it'll harm the
environment
don't
work as much it's bad no it's bad to
work stay home don't worry use use
government programs
don't
expect the same political rights you
once had we can't have that anymore
you're going to lose some of those
political rights
don't expect as prosperous a future as
we once had that look the 20th century
there was a lot of prosperity in america
you're not going to get that anymore
don't expect the same freedoms that you
once had don't just lower
lower your expectations this is the cry
of a regime that knows that it's in
trouble
the regime's saying stop criticizing us
stop questioning us just shut up and
deal with it okay and don't raise any
questions about this is the best things
could possibly be everything's right
we've made all the right decisions so
even though everything's falling apart
around you just know that you have no
right to criticize us
that this this reminds one of the soviet
union doesn't it
obviously the gas lines and the food
shortages and i mean that very directly
reminds one of the soviet union
and it raises some questions about the
stability of our regime there were three
big ideologies in the 20th century
fascism communism and liberalism
and fascism was the first one to fall
that one fell after the second world war
communism was the second one to fall
that one fell after the cold war and
then we were told that liberalism has
won we have reached the end of history
liberalism is going to be the dominant
ideology in perpetuity until the earth
fizzles and the sun explodes
we were told that about 30 years ago and
only 30 years later
are we seeing liberalism begin to crack
up a little bit
it's the timing is pretty interesting
you have fascism destroyed in the 1940s
then 40 years after that you have
communism destroyed in the 1980s
and now
30 to 40 years after that you're seeing
liberalism
having some real problems here
so what does that mean
it means that we haven't really reached
the end of history it means that we
haven't reached the final technocratic
utopia where we can suspend everybody's
political rights in the ordinary process
of politics where we debate things and
figure out how we want to run our
country and what we want to do
and it means that maybe we're going to
have to change course
the one thing i know right now
is that anyone telling you that we
should just keep the status quo whether
they are on the left or even some people
on the right the ones who regurgitate
the same stupid platitudes from 30 years
ago
the people who tell you just keep doing
the status quo everything is fine
nothing is abnormal nothing's going
wrong
we don't have any food on the shelves
and gas is going through the roof and we
no longer have faith in our elections
and our secretary of health is a man who
thinks that he's a woman but
everything is totally normal and fine
and your kids are learning radical
racial ideologies in schools and that
little boys can be little girls and the
family is collapsing and
but don't question anything because the
status quo is perfect if you're hearing
that from someone on the left or on the
right i think you got to stop listening
to that person okay because because that
person has has fallen all the way into
ideology
and and is is
engaging in a kind of delusion that is
not going to help us fix our problems
here in reality what are we doing about
the supply chain problem well if you ask
the white house if you ask our inept
ruling class they'll scoff at the very
question
just a question on the timing on the
supply chain issue yeah
actions that the president has taken
it was clear in march of 2020 when kobet
hit that that the supply chains across
the world had been disrupted even as as
the sort of work to fight back against
kobe proceeded
people it was it was crystal clear that
things were not improving on supply
chain people couldn't get dishwashers
and
and furniture and treadmills delivered
on time not to mention all sorts of
other things
so why is the tragedy of the short the
treadmill that's delayed
the tragedy of the treadmill that's
delayed that's what's going on right
families who are going to struggle to
heat their homes this winter people
whose money is not worth what it once
was where inflation is going through the
roof people who can't afford to buy
things at the grocery store can't afford
to buy their kids christmas presents
can't afford to
fill up the car it's just the tragedy of
the
of the late
treadmill right and what what uh saki is
implying here is that the supply chain
issues and the inflation it's a high
class problem this is what the white
house chief of staff said ron klain of
course the opposite is true not only
does inflation not disproportionately
hurt the rich it disproportionately
hurts the poor and this has been true
for a very very long time
this is
pretty ugly i don't think this is going
to play very well in virginia or
anywhere else in 2022 or even 2024 this
flippancy this glibness
oh it's not a big deal oh come on suck
it up oh stop it we're doing great
how dare you criticize what we're doing
here's what i know
before
before donald trump
was sort of backed into a corner i think
and allowed dr fauci and the libs to
shut down the world it's not as though
trump shut down the world it's he kind
of
he allowed it to happen but he wasn't
exactly pushing for it he was trying to
end that that lockdown early and then a
lot of republican governors did end the
lockdowns early but before that
things were going pretty great under
trump
they actually were improving
manufacturing was improving the economy
was improving real wages were growing
for the first time in a very long time
we were defending the american border at
least early on when when we thought that
was possible before the court struck
down a lot of of those protections
the international relations were
improving we were winding things
actually were getting better in a very
basic way
and under biden things actually are
getting worse they're getting worse on
the economy they're getting worse on
foreign policy they're getting worse
across the board
okay and there needs to be a consequence
for that
you know i don't think you need a phd in
political philosophy or foreign
relations or economics to just recognize
when things get better under a certain
set of policies and things get worse
under another set of policies we should
use the former policies we should defer
to that but the people who are pushing
the bad policies refuse to acknowledge
it okay
and they'll laugh and they'll mock the
question
you're seeing this ruling class
constantly moving the goal posts and
they never have to answer for it
you know we we are told follow the
science trust the experts do whatever
they want there was an incredible video
that was put together i didn't put this
together but someone put this together
put it out on twitter pointing out
that the ruling class
has been
walking back its claims just
specifically about vaccine efficacy
one percentage point
at a time
so now we have two vaccines that are
really quite effective the mrna vaccine
highly effective extraordinarily
efficacious 94 to 95 percent for mild to
moderate disease and
okay study fines highly effective see
all these headlines 100 percent
effective 100 100 effect 100 and all of
these
that now 96.6 95 994.
you just see all of these headlines
popping up now 90 now 89 now 88 now 87
now 86 and you can find it just google
any number
percent
vaccine effect now 58. now 56. no
it just keeps going down now 51. now 50.
oh my 47
they just keep 40 39 38.
[Music]
now you'll need an extra booster now
you'll need an extra plaster now you'll
need
i'm sure the way that this person put
this video together was he just googled
vaccine effectiveness followed by every
single percentage point and you will
find a news article for just about every
single one
now that seems pretty weird doesn't i
guess
the vaccine could become less effective
the longer you've had it
but then why not tell you that from the
very beginning from the very beginning
we were told 100 effective and then just
every every day just about it became
less and less and less and they're just
gonna keep moving the goal posts again
they're gonna tell us well once you get
the third fourth fifth sixth seventh jab
then it's 100 effective but it won't be
and there will be no answering for this
and by the way even after the
coronavirus
they're just going to keep up the public
health dictatorship on some other
pretext you're seeing this right now
with the allegedly conservative leader
in the united kingdom boris johnson who
has come out and said look okay this
covet thing it's bad and that's why we
took all this power and locked everyone
up and took away their rights
but you know kovit's going to go away
and actually there's a far greater
danger around the corner
we face a challenge that is even bigger
for humanity a threat to our way of life
that is ultimately far worse than covid
in just a couple of weeks
the world will assemble in glasgow
and i hope that many of you all of you
will be there
because the lesson of covid
is absolutely clear
we have to listen to the scientists
they're very often right you know
we need
urgent government action
but we must mobilize the markets we must
bring in the private sector because i
can i can deploy billions with the
approval of the chancellor obviously
but you
you in this room
you can deploy trillions
indeed i'm given to understand that
there are there is 24 trillion dollars
represented in this room
and we need to do this is an existential
threat from the sun monster my british
accents have really not been good in
recent weeks but
that's the argument he's making this is
the allegedly conservative leader oh
kovitt is really bad and that's why we
upended society and standards and took
everyone's rights but
once that goes away it's climate change
that's the big one and notice what he's
saying here too he's saying it's not
just enough for the government to focus
on this
the quote-unquote private sector needs
to as well the the corporatist public
private partnerships we all need to push
the same radical agenda that takes away
people's rights takes away their
traditions upends their way of life and
tells them to lower their expectations
of what they can do where they can go
how they can behave
and it's never going to end and and
some of us have been telling you from
the very beginning of the lockdown and
the epidemic on covid that this is never
going to end it won't really be 15 days
it's going to go on forever and ever
until we take that power back and people
have said oh it's a conspiracy theory oh
you're just worried oh you're hysterical
don't well there it is there's boris
johnson telling you and he's not even
the lib candidate
he is ostensibly the conservative it's
not really right versus left here it's
the whole
system you are seeing a crisis
of
the regimes it's sometimes called
neo-liberalism
but that's that's where you're seeing
the crisis it's not just one party or
another i mean i'm all for owning the
left and i'm all for you know smacking
down and destroying the democrats or
whatever but it's really bigger than
that it's really
the whole
system
meanwhile when you look outside of the
west
the the situation is even bleaker
because our enemies
the people who are challenging our
global hegemony the people who come from
different cultures in a different
civilization
are eating our lunch
speaking of foreign nations and trusting
the experts
china has just launched
a hypersonic missile that can be fitted
with a nuclear warhead and what this
means
in layman's terms as i understand them
i'm no rocket scientist myself
is that you've got some missiles they
can fly through the air
and then you've got some missiles that
can fly up and up and up higher so it's
a little easier to move and then it
comes back down right and you have
missile defense systems to deal with
these
but then you've got some missiles that
go
way way up really really high
where they can then
fly you know outside the intense pool of
earth's gravitation they can fly really
really far distances really really
quickly and then come right back down
and hit their target even if they're
targets on the other side of the world
and missile defense systems are not
particularly effective against this type
of warhead and china just tested one
they tested
a drive-by you know
trial
nuclear
missile
and
it was quite effective
we are here
in the united states
are worried about germs
and germs that by the way china sent to
us and we are here in the west broadly
worried about the sun monster and trying
to shut down our
our way of life because of the sun
monster and we are here in the west
throwing parties for ourselves to
celebrate the fact that a man is the
first woman admiral even though he's
never been in the military a day in his
life and how wonderful this is and
creating
now
multiple months to celebrate people's
sexual desires
and
deluded gender identities
and we're just so happy about and we
just man we couldn't we couldn't pat
ourselves on the back any harder got my
i'm gonna have a bruise on my back from
how much i'm patting myself on the back
here in the west
meanwhile while we are twiddling our
thumbs and and worse
our enemies are testing out hypersonic
missiles hey white house hey jen saki uh
what do you think about
this development that our number one
enemy uh is testing out these
extraordinary weapons that could pose a
serious threat to our interests and even
to our nation what are we supposed to do
about that gensake
can you comment on reports that china
tested a nuclear-capable hypersonic
missile over this summer to the surprise
of u.s officials are they accurate and
did you raise concerns about china's
nuclear capability
uh well i know general uh the secretary
austin i should say was asked this
question this morning and addressed it
uh but i'm not going to comment on the
specific report i can say and would echo
what he said which is generally speaking
we've made clear are concerned about the
military capabilities that the prc
continues to pursue uh and we have been
consistent in our approach with china uh
we welcome stiff competition but do we
not we don't do not want that
competition to veer into conflict and
that is certainly what we convey
privately as well
we welcome stiff competition
you
your answer to our
greatest
geopolitical
adversary developing a weapon that we
can't quite beat at the moment
a weapon that could land a nuclear
warhead in the united states very very
very quickly your answer is
we welcome stiff competition
what planet are you living on
this kind of talk it sounds like it's
just more of the same glib and flippant
talk that that we've become accustomed
to from gensake and to a degree i
suppose it is
but it's deeper than that
it comes from the rot
of this liberal regime
that believes that people don't really
go to war all that much and that people
don't really have fundamentally opposing
interests and cultures but that we're
all we're all just trying to make a buck
look and once
once we get some more jobs and iphones
for people in afghanistan they're going
to stop warring against one another
that's what barack obama told us once we
open up a few more markets once we send
a few more movies over there to china
once we buy a few more sneakers from
their nike factories we're not going to
go to war we don't we don't look we're
all just trying to make a buck
it's just the free marketplace of ideas
the free marketplace of
literal markets we just we just welcome
that stiff competition i do not welcome
nuclear competition from our chief enemy
okay i don't at least i don't
i guess i view the world a little bit
differently these are not serious people
jen saki and joe biden and kamala harris
and pete bootaj and all the rest of them
they are not serious people they are
living in a fantasy land biden in
particular has spent the last 30 years
cheering on the rise of china as
recently as what 10 years ago
he applauded the rise of china the
entrance of china into the
world trade organization the entrance of
china
really into the world marketplace oh
it's wonderful a rising tide lifts all
ships right well i don't know
looks like our ship is possibly going to
capsize if we don't stabilize it
no it's great it's wonderful let's go
we're going to take six months paternity
leave during
during a cri take 10 months why would
you come home you're doing that joyful
work
of staying at home with your baby so why
would you have to come in and
run our ship of state
why does joe biden doesn't need to
campaign he doesn't need to pay
attention really to anything at all
why why do we need to do any of it
jen saki doesn't need to give real
answers to the american we don't need to
do any of it we're all just pretending
and
we're being told that delusions are
compassionate and that there's nothing
more wonderful and and uh charitable
than
than pretending that it's not that that
national security threats are not a
threat or pretending that
hordes and hordes of migrants being
brought over by criminal cartels are
that's not a problem and enforcing our
laws is not a big deal
and
pretending that men are women that's
totally fine we're being told that's not
that's actually compassionate to live in
those lies well the consequence of
living in those lies is that your
civilization collapses okay the the
consequence of living in lies is that
people who are
more in touch with reality are going to
eat your lunch and that's what's going
on right now
in this country we can no longer even
reliably conduct our own
elections
stacey abrams just came out we're going
to run a little late but i've got to
play the clip stacey abrams just came
out
to once again suggests that she is the
legitimate governor of georgia
just because you win doesn't mean you're
one
we've got folks who are ready to take
back what they think is theirs but they
are not entitled to our progress
they are not entitled to our justice
they are not entitled to our votes
but either we use them or we lose them
i come from a state where i was not
entitled to become the governor
but as an american citizen and a citizen
of george i'm gonna fight for every
person who has the right to vote to be
able to cast that vote and here in
virginia you need to cast that vote for
tara mcauliffe
she's saying just because you win
doesn't mean you really win i was not
entitled to be governor she's pushing
this whole thing that the election was
rigged now i was reliably informed that
if you question election results you're
an insurrectionist terrorist threat to
our democracy so these are obviously
whenever people bring up january 6th the
insurrection whatever i mean just mock
them just laugh at them they don't
they're not being serious they're being
very disingenuous but furthermore it's
worth pointing out that since at least
the year 2000 if not sooner
we have not been able to conduct
elections where we trust the results the
left didn't trust the results in 2000
the right uh the left also didn't trust
the results in 2016. the right didn't
trust the results in 2020. that is a
joke and if we just keep pretending that
everything's going fine and everything's
normal and stop complaining and the
status quo is great we are going to see
the rot progress and progress and
progress the first step to fixing a
problem is admitting that you have one
i'm michael knowless the michael knowles
show i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021. on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show